hey how long how many times you think
you have to go to Machado before you use
your black belt think four more times
and post on Instagram don't do do you
think if you get casted in Joker -
you're eating your black belt it's cast
all right that's it cast it and also
don't don't I find my processed or my
journey I don't like it you're right
everyone's journeys different don't like
everyone's journeys different I'm gonna
be first name is Aston coaches you can I
have a we have a plan right now I'm
working defense yeah hell yeah so my my
defense is guy you know you know you're
in trouble before I made with on the
ground yeah you know you're in trouble
if heating goes hey man Ashton Kutcher's
gonna be in her tomorrow and he needs
somebody to roll it you know you [ __ ]
up by good girl right he's a brown belt
yeah that's what six for yeah he's also
good doesn't matter yeah he's gonna [ __ ]
you up dude and I want to be there for
that yeah for now please now for now and
if I play his game yeah if I play his
game for now if I play his game yet what
I just when you get your black belt did
we start my fighting you talking about
you did say anything kitch was gonna be
Janet be quiet
look at that dude yeah he's been doing
for a while yeah man he got obsessed
with a girl he can tell me he's [ __ ]
good he's good is that Connor yeah
just side by side gone on McGregor
strange oh wow City okay that's he can
saying that pitcher would beat Conor
McGregor in jujitsu maybe cuz he's so
much bigger in just pure jujitsu I don't
know that kind of McGregor's a wrestler
oh I don't know if I'm taking this guy
you know Ashton Kutcher I know how long
it's taking I'm sure he has good skills
for regular jujitsu that he's telling
but when you're talking you sit
full-time actor
dad you anytime up the grind that Conor
McGregor's been on yeah it's almost but
I love you severe I love that I love
that about fighting right to me let's I
love I love I love the difference I love
the difference
it's my favorite thing I love I love
[ __ ] with you like that hey you were
a little serious though no I was yes
so does I'm really not serious that's
just like I just like getting you going
especially about something like Connor
because Connors not known as a wrestler
but what people seem so just to show you
what I died you know this what people
don't realize is that for example like
with with cubby burger man get off
however you say it's never gonna come at
all never come at off your mondo meat oh
yeah that [ __ ] that takes
everybody and wraps him up what people
don't remember about the fight with
Connor even though he beat the [ __ ] out
of Connor is Connor kept him at bay for
a while by controlling his rest and
stuff because Connor had brought in a
dude from Dagestan in his training camp
who wrestled like that I still got
taking down the promises you watching
y'all Connors just a box it get be your
your watch him against the very first
battle in the world so the combo so the
cop he's just a striker hold on the guy
has got to the top of the mount at 145
155 you don't think he knows grappling a
hell of an athlete he's a good fighter
but his gym he's doing wrestling with
the best of the best all the time
jujitsu wrestling boxing does he give I
didn't know you could heroes with Danis
and that's pretty the best friends that
I mean that's they travel the world
together enroll if got non-stop Danis is
what 175 sucks down from on D 95
phenomenal phenomenal grappler monster
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]